good morning believe nation its Evan my
one word is believe and I believe in
people more than they believe in
themselves and my sincere hope is that
if you see in yourself what I see in you
you'll be able to change the planet so
to help you on your journey today's
message is make today count over to you
Nik voyage I want to make sure that
every single day that you are alive that
you make it count and you take the suite
of choices of life that God has given
you because I want to ask you right now
if this was your last thirty Seconds to
breathe how would you be remembered well
you're a giver encouraged or where you
were take up will you a bit a person did
you encourage people to in your actions
in your life did you help them or did
you discourage them did you take that
time to say hey how you doing and they
look to the ground and say oh you know
I'm okay no look at me how are you doing
we are here for one another this is the
ministry this is Jesus this is the light
and I want to tell you I'm sure that if
any one of us were as was at a road and
there was a three year old kid in the
middle of the street sitting down
playing with rocks on the street and a
bus was coming and the bus was about to
kill him you have plenty of time to get
up off your seat go save that kid will
you say that kid of course you will you
don't know his name you're gonna save
that kid you don't know his religion
you're gonna save that kid you don't
know his sexual orientation you're gonna
save that kid because what we are the
light and love in the bridge to Jesus
Christ we need to understand that it's
not just doing what we think we need to
achieve or have some people think that
things get easier when you get married
I'll go talk to some married people some
single people I like I'm not happy but I
know I'm gonna be happy when I get
married dude if you ain't happy single
you ain't gonna be happy married Kenny
here
amen yeah you guys already know it right
you got talking so what do you want how
do you act who are you make today count
dream big and never give up one of the
most common questions that I get asking
a lot of interviews is usually right at
the end they say do you have anything
else to share with our audience you have
anything else to share anything else
that's on your mind that you want to let
us know about and I almost always will
default to make today count make what
you're doing right now really important
one final word for influencers just to
go out there and create their best work
and put their message out there in the
world it's important just remember that
what you're doing is important stop
shrinking down stop wait until tomorrow
like the work that you're doing in this
very moment better means something that
you want to go and show your grandkids
the more that you spend your time
thinking that this moment right now is
important the more you're gonna do
important things I say that because a
lot of you guys are not taking enough
action you're not living up to your
capabilities because you feel there's so
much time because you you may know where
you want to go you may have belief that
you can get there you may know all the
steps that you need to take to be able
to do that thing and part of that also
means because you figured it out you
don't actually want to go and do the
steps because the most fun part was
figuring out the strategy the hard part
is actually doing the execution and so
you know that it will work but you don't
want to do the work dig in day out to
actually go out and do it and so the
mental exercise was more the challenge
and actually going building the company
but you feel is a lot of time like okay
I can do it tomorrow I can do it the
next day I could do it the next day you
know they can always push it off and
just not pushing it off till next year
or in three years some of you do that
but for a lot of people still just
pushing it off to the next day or the
next week challenges it still doesn't
happen the next day or the next week
there's always a reason why to push it
off again and to push it off again to
push it up again and you know it's nice
outside so I'm gonna go for a walk or
you know family issues that you have to
deal with or or or or or like there's
always something right you're never
going to have the time to do it
he's never gonna have the perfect moment
where oh you know like ours just free up
magically every day of your life to be
able to work on this thing and so you
have to make a count make today count if
you had a practice of waking up every
day and whatever it takes to get you
feeling like today is important whether
it's reading the book that motivates you
whether it's Washington espresso video
in the morning whether it's remembering
that like what you do today you want to
show your grandkids one day and be proud
of like I made this thing happen today
whatever that thing is that that feeling
inside you that doesn't just make you
think bold thoughts but that today
matters that what I do today actually
makes a difference what I'm about to do
in the next hour actually makes a
difference if whatever you need to do to
get yourself in that mindset if you did
that consistently your output would
explode because even as I'm saying this
a lot of you will be understanding it
but you still won't do it and you still
feel like you know that idea that I have
I could do it tomorrow I'll still do it
tomorrow I'll do it I'll get it done
I'll do it tomorrow
and if you lost today even if you do do
it tomorrow you've lost today and so
whatever you need to do but every day
you're thinking to myself today matters
what I create today matters it's gonna
last a lifetime
it's that important this next video that
I make has to be that important this
next product you make has to be that
important that customer email that you
send out today has to be that important
I want to change that person's life with
this customer support email and I'm
about to send out whatever you do in
your day-to-day work your day-to-day job
you did it a business plus all the extra
stuff that you have to do to get your
company off the ground make today count
so the question today is I'm curious
what is it for you that increases the
importance what do you need to do on a
daily basis that will help you really
feel that today counts and hopefully by
sharing that it encourages you to do it
more regularly but also gives ideas to
everybody else and elimination of things
that they could try so that they
understand that today counts to leave it
down the comments below really curious
see we have to say and also if you leave
a comment within the first couple hours
those video going live we have the
chance to win one of our two daily
prizes I also want to give a quick shout
out to Laney burke Laney thank you so
much for picking up a copy of my book
your one word I really really
really means a lot to me and I hope
you're enjoying the read thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love and I'll see you again
tomorrow morning for another shot of
espresso
[Music]
the first thing I want you to know that
success is is not a destination it's a
journey think of success as a process
let me let me illustrate it and explain
it this way if you go to college you
work hard and then in four or five years
depending on what kind of degree you're
working on it and in today's society
sometimes six or seven years but but
eventually you comes the day of
graduation and you're all excited and
your family is there and your friends
are there and and you're there with your
classmates you've got your cap and your
gown and and you know that there's going
to be a time in that ceremony where
you're going to walk across stage and
the president Provost somebody's gonna
shake your hand hand you the Diploma
congratulate you and and you're gonna
get off the other side I'm gonna have
presents waiting for you and they'll be
taking pictures and everybody will be
shaking your hands say congratulations
today you become a success your college
graduate now now my friend you did not
become a success the day that you got
your diploma now what you did have
happened to you in that ceremony is you
got recognized for success the Diploma
is recognition of what you have done the
previous four or five years you see
you're a success in your freshman year
when you decided to not drop out of
school like some of the other classmates
and decided to stick to it and you're a
success every time you studied for a
test and you were success every time you
did a project or or did a writing
assignment you see you're a success all
through all through school your success
every day success is a daily thing not a
destination thing the day you got the
diploma
you just got recognized for the success
that you already were now that's very
essential because so many times people
have it have a tendency to devalue the
moment today what they do is they
greatly value the destination and so
they kind of talk about well when I get
there or if I arrive there or when I do
that or when I accomplish this and they
don't understand
that successes a daily thing and I'm
here to share with you that the secret
of success is determined by your daily
agenda in fact I wrote a book a few
years ago called today manners
I'm passionate about that book because
what it does is it helps you it helps me
to understand that we make decisions and
then we manage decisions and and too
often we think I will make a decision
for example you're saying I'm going to
make a decision to be a coach or I'm
going to make a decision now you know
what I'm gonna make a decision to to be
a public speaker I want to be a
communicator well congratulate young
congratulations you've made a wonderful
decision coach speaking good decisions
but that won't make you a successful
coach that will make you a successful
communicator it's not the decision that
makes you you've got to make the
decision by managing it and you manage
the decision on a daily basis in other
words what you want to be tomorrow
you've got to do today you visualize
tomorrow that gives you hope but that's
your motivation and that's your dream
you've nothing wrong with that you
visualize tomorrow but you value today
what's that mean that means that what I
do every day is either getting me closer
to that vision that dream that goal or
it's really driving me farther away from
it you see every day we are either
repairing or we're preparing you see if
I messed up yesterday guess what I get
to do today fix yesterday in other words
if I didn't do the right thing yesterday
what I got to do today is I've got to
repair I've got to go back make amends
backtrack put the car in reverse put my
life in reverse I've got to go back
there I've got to repair now every day I
spend repairing I'm not spending
preparing well you see we repair when we
fail to manage
the decisions that we've made we prepare
when we on a daily basis manage the
decisions that we've made so your
footprints to success are really
footprints of success because every step
that is made and taken based upon the
goals that you have for your life and
you're managing those goals correctly
every step is the progressive
realization of success in your life and
by the way oh what you you'll get the
Diploma you'll get the certificate but
but when you get that you didn't arrive
it just is another step in preparing you
to reach your potential each one of us
should live our life as if we'll never
learn everything we never need to learn
we'll never be able to accomplish
everything we wanted to accomplish we
won't be able to experience everything
we wanted to experience we should live
our life every day hungry understanding
that we are to live until we die you see
I think success can't be summarized in a
flippant degree or program or diploma or
arrival I think today if you are
learning to coach if you are learning to
speak if you're doing the things that
are essential to the decisions and
you're managing those decisions well can
I say something to you congratulations
you are already a success now guess what
over time
it shows up you've heard the expression
you maybe even a said it yourself you've
heard the expression I'm sure I've
worked all my life to become an
overnight success so it works all of a
sudden somebody recognizes you all of a
sudden somebody congratulate you you
didn't get good at that moment you've
been good for a long time it just showed
up someday